-Our next guest is
a Tony winning actor
you know from shows such as
"Masters of Sex"
and "Impeachment:
American Crime Story."
She stars in "B Positive,"
which airs two new back-to-back
episodes this Thursday,
starting at 9:00 p.m. on CBS
and Paramount+.
Let's take a look.
-While I have you all,
let's make a mental note
to check the smoke alarms
next week.
It's battery changing season.
What? What?
-Gina, we don't usually talk
work here.
-Oh, right. Right. Sorry.
Yeah, we're off the clock.
Hey, what are you
doing this weekend?
-Oh, I'm actually
taking Monday off.
I'm going on a hiking trip
with some friends.
-Oh, that sounds great.
Just remember to put
in your time card tomorrow
because they're due on Friday.
Now, Gabby, you sent
that e-mail to everyone, right?
-I could check, but I sent it
from my work computer
and we're not at work.
-Starting to feel like it.
-Please welcome back to the
show,
our friend Annaleigh Ashford.
How are you, Annaleigh?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello!
Aww, it's so good to see.
-It's so good to see you
as well.
I do wish you were
here and -- yeah, there you go.
-Oh, God, what a warm hug.
-You -- So, doing this sitcom,
I imagine one of the draws,
being a stage actor
like you are,
is getting to do a show
in front of
the live studio audience.
But because of COVID,
a lot of the episodes you taped
were just in front of the crew.
How was that?
-I give the crew
baked goods and alcohol.
I'm just...
[ Laughs ]
I wish.
You know, thank God.
They're a wonderful audience.
And, hey, if the crew laughs --
You know.
If the crew laughs,
then you know it went well.
-Yes.
-But sometimes I feel
like I'm doing like
an eternal Wednesday matinee,
like, the Wednesday matinee
that won't end.
But that's -- hey, I'm so happy
to be making somebody laugh
somewhere.
You just hope that
it goes through the ether
in the land of television,
and I imagine the laughs.
But I do remember on stage
having one particular
Wednesday matinee
where it was so quiet
that it felt like
nobody was out there.
And when we looked
in the front row,
there was one woman
who was taking a full-out nap.
And it was
it was a three-act play,
so it was a long play
and she took a long nap.
And then, you know, you start
to wonder if she was alive.
[ Laughter ]
She woke up at the end.
The applause at the end
of the show woke her up,
but, you know, it sort of
feels like that sometimes.
-That's very -- that's very rude
for everybody to clap
and wake up that poor woman.
-I mean, hello.
She was having a lovely respite.
-So a three-act play,
those intermissions
must be so weird with you
and the other actors when
you realize how quiet it is.
Do you talk about it backstage?
Is there like a real like...?
-Immediately.
Like, the first thing you do
when you got offstage
when you're doing a show is go,
"What's happening
with this audience?"
whether they're good or bad.
You know, they're like --
I only wish the audience knew
how much we talked about them.
And there's like, you know,
a thousand of them,
but they are one in our minds.
-Yeah.
You know how sometimes there's
a Q&A after a show
where the audience
can ask the cast --
you should do a Q&A
where you, the cast,
get to ask the audience
some questions like,
"What did you think
you were buying a ticket for?"
-Why did you take melatonin
before coming?
Could you have waited?
-So, your character in the show
owns and runs a nursing home.
As a young performer,
you actually found your way
to performing at nursing homes.
How did that happen, and did you
enjoy that experience?
-You know,
it's such a strange story
that I, like, forgot happened
until a couple weeks
into working out of the show.
I was like, "Oh, you know what?
I feel like I've been here
before," because I have.
When I was a kid, I danced
at this amazing dance studio,
and to practice numbers
before dance competitions,
we would play nursing homes.
We would do like 30 dance
numbers at these nursing homes.
And sometimes they were, like,
very risque.
Like, I remember the older girls
did a Janet Jackson number
and they wore, like, bustiers
and, like, ripped-up jeans
and like door frames.
And it was -- it was a big hit
at the nursing home.
And I would sing.
And I remember at the end
of one of our gigs,
the director of the nursing home
came up and asked me
if I wanted to do my own set.
So I came back
with my karaoke machine,
and I had a little mic
attached to a boombox,
and I had about 15 songs
and little karaoke tapes
in order,
and I wrote my own jokes,
and I wore a tuxedo.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Why? Why did that happen?
It was very uncomfortable.
-They must have loved you,
right?
-They love to be,
but they were like,
"Why is this small woman
doing this show for us?"
And I was 10.
-But now you have --
Is it true that you have always
befriended people
that were maybe a generation
or two above your age group?
-Yes. You know, I've always
thought it's sort of obnoxious
when people are like,
"I'm an old soul. Oh."
But I, you know...
I'm sort of -- I've always
connected with people
who are of an older generation
than I am.
And I -- You know, I'm working
with a bunch of legends
with a capital "L" right now.
Any time Linda Lavin
will tell me any story,
I sit down at her feet.
But, yeah,
we used to live next door
actually to my great-grandma
when I was growing up.
So my cousin Tyler and I
would walk home from school
and we'd go next door
and hang out
with Grandma Ashford
for a couple of hours.
And she -- We were in charge
of giving her her medicine,
and she somehow
would make a game
out of throwing it
across the room
'cause she just really
didn't want to take it.
And so we were sort of in charge
of, like, finding her pills.
We'd find -- Over the years,
we found them in the couch.
We found them under glasses.
They were in the plants.
I really was like, "Why are we
making her take this?"
You know, it's probably like
extra magnesium.
Like, what's the point?
-[ Laughs ] You have --
We've talked before
about your son, Jack.
I think the last time
you were here
he was maybe only one
or two years old.
He's five and a half now.
-Oh, my God.
-How is he doing?
-Yes, I was still --
I no longer give him milk
from my breasts.
That's what was happening
last time I was here.
-We've crossed
the milk threshold.
Congratulations.
-Yes.
Yeah, we're done doing that.
Thank God.
But, yeah, he's doing great.
He's so big now, which is crazy.
He's really, really, really
into superheroes.
He's super into Spider-Man
right now specifically.
-Does he know you are
in show business?
Does he know his mom
is an actor?
-It's just started happening,
which is so banan--
I mean, you know,
it's like such a funny thing
being in the business
and then growing up,
not in the business, you know?
I can't imagine what it feels
like to have a kid who just like
has parents who are friends
with actors that they see
in things, you know?
He'll be like, "Mom, do you --"
Now he's started being like,
"Do you know them?"
in every movie that we watch.
You know, and I don't.
But now,
when I fight with my husband
or a couple of days ago,
I got really upset
about something,
I was like, "I don't understand
what's happening!"
And he was like,
"Mom, are you crying,
or are you working on a scene?"
That's literally what he said.
He'll go, "Are you running
lines?" when we fight.
And we just go, "Yes, we've got
a big scene coming up."
-"Your father and I
are rehearsing."
-"Oh, we're doing 'Who's Afraid
of Virginia Woolf' again."
-[ Laughs ]
I was lucky enough to see you
on stage
doing the great
Stephen Sondheim musical
"Sunday in the Park
with George."
I can only imagine,
like all of us,
that you were deeply affected
by his passing.
What was your -- do you have
a fond memory with Stephen
you'd be willing to share?
-Absolutely.
I mean, I have so many,
but one thing that keeps
coming back to me
is how, as an artist,
he was never done.
You know, one of the most famous
lines
in "Sunday in the Park
with George" is
"Anything you do,
let it come from you,
then it will be new.
Give us more to see."
And, you know, for all of us
who want to make art,
that should sort of be a mantra.
And it was for him,
and the art was never done.
You know,
he was always giving us notes,
always giving himself notes.
And I always think
it's sort of magical.
He loved puzzles.
He loved board games.
And on opening night,
he gave us all a puzzle.
And so I just feel
like he left us
all of these beautiful puzzles
to keep figuring out.
You know,
that's sort of his legacy.
These shows are like
exquisite works of art
that we can keep working out,
you know?
-It is an incredible gift
that he left us
with all that work
that we can continue to enjoy,
and it is always so wonderful
to talk to you.
Thanks so much
for making the time, Annaleigh.
-Oh, my pleasure.
Good to see you.
Bye!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Annaleigh Ashford, everybody!
Two new back-to-back episodes
of "B Positive"
air this Thursday,
starting at 9:00 p.m.
on CBS and Paramount+.